yo the night that you battled freeway
give me the background of that night
because was it he they were on Hot 97
that night or something yeah earlier
that night yeah she started it and then
Swiss was like I got because obviously
freeways from Philly you're from Philly
so that happened at a recording studio
yeah so did you pull up knowing y'all
were gonna battle
and did he know you guys were gonna
battle
now is already in the studio and I went
to McDonald's when I heard them on the
radio rapping and talking about they
want to battle and
anybody could get it so they wasn't
talking about me but I felt like they
was right so when I got back to the
studio
um I told Swiss about it and he like I
don't matter Jay-Z coming to her studio
tonight anyway
so I'm just sitting around knowing Jay-Z
got there he introduced them to me
introduced me is like
him like the next one yeah and Jay-Z
took offense today like what you ain't
had my artist I got the hottest [__]
in that's how I started getting
competitive oh start talking he called
them up we called out people's up next
thing you know the studio was crowded
and we battled oh man that was a
legendary moment man yeah
um I'd heard that you guys were supposed
to run it back it just didn't end up
getting worked out
yeah we're supposed to be with the URL
with smack we were supposed to do
another one but I don't know
business-wise it ain't paying just
didn't line up yeah that's fair yeah
that was a I feel like that because
correct me if I'm wrong but that came
out did that video come out like right
away or was it like later on that we
actually saw the video
nah it took some time man at first
at first it was um
it was on audio like a DJ got a copy of
the tape and put it on audio so a lot of
people only they just had it on Napster
would you would like download battles
off Napster I think it was even before
that time because it was on VHS team so
the DJ put it on you know CD on mixtape
and that's how people started to hear it
around you know around the world they
was hearing the audio but didn't see the
visual
and um
it was floating around in the industry
certain key people got a chance to see
the visual but the internet wasn't out
it was like folklore it was like it was
like some Word of Mouth [__] like yo I
saw this tape that that [__] don't exist
I know I saw it yeah exactly and it was
no YouTube no internet for people to
really get access to it so
it was just like big on the streets and
building up for a long period of time
and then when YouTube and the internet
dropped and everything then they
re-uploaded it and people started
getting to see it all around the world
yeah no legendary man so you uh take me
back to
obviously the full surface era was crazy
uh you had three great bodies of work
hit records all of that
what was it like running around in
Arizona with DMX and swiss beats in the
early 2000s bro yeah it was it was dope
man it was fun man for people who don't
know Swiss beats had kind of like
planted his feet pretty heavy out in AZ
he was a part owner of like a car
dealership a nightclub that's at the
same time DMX is out there uh and it was
a lot of energy out there and I'm from
AZ so I gotta ask because I know you
were out there a lot yeah it was a lot
of energy
um
I liked it I mean I was from Philly man
so you know you have a you've been to
Philly you see I would I have I just
told Ness I've literally just rode a
train through Philly from DC to New York
and
and I was telling him how we stopped in
Chester at like one of the stops and I
looked outside and I was like what the
[__] where are we at right yeah well if
you ever go to Philly I mean it's some
nice Parts but
the majority of the parts is like a big
difference from Arizona so when I got
over there and I seen how people living
how nice it is
how dope it was and plus I'm out there
working on my music so I got a different
type of reception so I was loving it man
Swiss had the club I was performing
there was lit was turned what was like
being around DMX during that era of x
because that was like he was like in the
desert with them ATV he's heavy man yeah
I actually went back to Arizona too like
um for my third album when I after I
fought the case and I came home I
started working on a new project I went
to Arizona to do that before the
accident and
um that was the like the last time I was
like really around X went to his crib
um but Dr Benjamin to his house now Dr
Benjamin was in the belly movie with him
preaching to him and all of that so then
I'll bring them to X house and we all
vibing out chilling and um
it was dope man X was in a positive Zone
I was liking how he was I mean carrying
it at that time and one of the memorable
moments is when he showed me this giant
scorpion we was riding past he was on
the four wheeler we was in the car he
was leading us back out to the road to
leave and then he turned around he said
yo y'all want to see a scorpion and be
like yeah and he took a rock and he
threw it down and it like
made the Scorpion tail come off and he
picked it up like this and that poison
was Dripping in me like look look
I heard his crib was like like in
Carefree like deep like
yeah and that's how I remembered them
like he was just like he ain't give a
[__] about nothing he was just wild
but good dude so that's your last memory
I mean remember with X and Arizona yeah
busting the Scorpion Stinger off and oh
yeah yeah with Dr Ben him and belly and
the whole vibe it was it was it was
super dope